hey there guys thanks for tuning in so a
bit of an unusual video today i'm going
to be
breaking some exciting news first of all
we've now surpassed 250
000 subscribers that's a quarter of a
million which is
so awesome and just want to once again
say a huge thank you to all of you for
all of your support genuinely i feel
blessed i think i've got the best
comments section on all of youtube like
have you seen
other comments sections you guys are
supportive you give me ideas for videos
genuinely i can't thank you enough and
i'm only sorry that these days
i struggle to find time to answer
everyone but i read almost everything
and every now and then i jump in there
so really appreciate it and
just want to thank you so much and
now the big news some of you may have
noticed the astute among you
that on amazon there's a new book listed
by adam schnitzky called functional
training
and beyond and this i'm now allowed to
finally announce will be released in
january
next year and it's essentially it's not
the same thing as super functional
training
it's not a direct sequel it's something
completely different but it has many of
the same
kind of concepts and the similar ethos
basically
it's a kind of journey through training
starting from
actually old-time strongmen and even
further back than that the beginnings of
physical culture in ancient greece
all the way through to modern day and
looking at how fitness and training has
evolved
and become more functional and how we
can combine different
concepts and elements from all of these
different training modalities that we've
touched on throughout the years in order
to create something that's truly
comprehensive that
improves mind and body endurance and
strength explosiveness and just
everything else
so as you guys know the whole ethos of
the bioneer is that
training shouldn't just be about
improving your numbers on three key
lifts or on
building an aesthetic physique and
ignoring all the muscles that don't look
so good in the mirror it should be about
improving the way you feel and the way
you perform and i believe
functional training helps us to do this
it gives us the tools we need to train
in a way that
helps us perform better as well as just
look better and across
a whole range of different disciplines
obviously athletes use functional
training as a way to improve themselves
for
sports and whatever their chosen event
is but we can all use functional methods
to make ourselves
more effective in our daily lives
whether it's moving house whether it's
getting into an unexpected difficult
situation or it's just
running around and climbing trees and
feeling awesome that's the best part of
it training this way
is awesome and you feel like a comic
book superhero or like you're in an
action scene from an 80s movie
rather than just standing there curling
weights but of course then i also talk
about super functional training which is
the idea of taking functional training
and taking it beyond what is necessary
instead of just training to do the
things you want to be able to do
better your training in order to be able
to do entirely new things things you
don't need to be able to do
because imagine what it'd be like to be
a little bit faster a little bit more
endurance a little bit stronger
have more energy and be a little bit
sharper and more focused
and that's the idea of my approach to
training and that's what i talk about in
this book at
length so that means we're going to be
looking at things like old-time
strongman training
parkour to movement training
bodybuilding powerlifting
the way that athletes train we're going
to be talking about different
nomadic cultures and all kinds of just
out there stuff that
so many people never even realize exists
and it can be applied to your training
in order to bring about
all kinds of awesome benefits it's not
just about being fit
it's about being awesome like i say this
isn't the same thing as super functional
training which is still available
as an e-book and that includes a full
program and diet advice it's a very
different beast
whereas functional training and beyond
is a book it'll take you from
beginning to end and it's published by a
proper publishing company
mango which have been fantastic at every
stage of the way
and that also means of course that it's
nicely edited it's got a cool cover
design
and the stuff they've done with it looks
really great it's a huge and
comprehensive book if you enjoy any of
the stuff on this channel
then you'll find something to enjoy in
there it's currently available for
pre-order
check it out i'll put a link to the
amazon listing in the description down
below and that's the other thing of
course you're not buying it from my
website so you don't need paypal you can
buy it through amazon and you can just
use all the methods that you're
used to or deliver to anywhere and of
course all those people that don't enjoy
reading ebooks on a little screen it is
available on kindle but it's also
available
in a physical format and i'll be sharing
more about this book
over the coming weeks and months in the
build up to it i'll be doing an unboxing
i'll be reading chapters from it and
discussing some of these subjects that
crop up so
stay tuned for that stuff there's also
some other exciting new announcements
coming to the channel so
keep your eyes peeled for those and i
will see you then
in the meantime back to our regular
programming i'm just out here right now
filming some workout footage from my
next video
which is all about bucky training so if
that sounds cool then please subscribe
thanks again so much for your support
like this video etc etc
thanks a ton and bye for now
you